the shiki science show clips
exactly and as you kind of already just
alluded to um the the real like one of
the great ways of understanding like the
underlying mechanisms is that you can
then see how different interventions
have a similar impact and so obviously
you just mentioned their fasting and how
it's not just about the diet's
composition but also diet timing can
also
in a similar way activate or repress
these different signaling pathways and
so um you coined um the fasting
mimicking diet and so i was wondering if
you could explain about how you came to
and create
this diet and how it relates to fasting
and also going back to um activating
these longevity programs
yes so um the um
the festive meeting diet uh people
sometimes think you know just woke up in
the morning and came up with with this
and just become my favorite project
but in fact you know as i was a student
at roy walford back in 1992 and roy was
this guru of nutrition and longevity
right that's all he he spent his life
trying to figure out you know how to
make people live longer with nutrition
and i realized that you know what he was
doing color restriction so what if you
take an organism and you take about 20
30 of the calories away
and i realized
that had obviously incredible
uh power but incredible problems uh
associated with it
and so then i spent the next almost 30
years um
trying to figure out um how can you get
that incredible power you know and
without the problems
and and making it feasible to people
um
and but then i started working with
bacteria and yeast that were starving
and i saw that you could completely
starve a bacteria or a yeast and they
live very long
and i thought this is really strange
right it's very counterintuitive it's
like why will any organism live so long
just
completely complete absence of nutrients
uh
but then i started thinking what if we
just did it very quickly
or quickly for a few days and then allow
the system to go back to the normal food
you know and um yeah they worked very
well in they initially initially was
just water only fasting
for let's say five days every couple
weeks and or four days every couple
weeks and then eventually went through
fasting meeting diet
in mice as little as once a month for
five days
and uh and in people now we think you
know it could be as little as
once every three months
um and and why is a
a fascinating diet well we started doing
a cancer clinical trial at usc norris
cancer center
and and this had water only fasting
and
and nobody none of the patient wanted to
do water only fasting and we thought of
course i mean our naive
group of
scientists and oncologists are of course
people are gonna do water only fasting
they have cancer they're very motivated
right this was the reason
and it doesn't work like that right so
even with cancer people say i don't i
just don't i'm not convinced by this i
don't want to do it it's too hard
um yeah so then then we went back to the
national cancer institute and the
national student aging
and asked to you know develop the
fasting mimicking diet for cancer
patients and this was developed for
constipation
and and then realized that you know with
the
if you have a dietitian
and the fasting making diet then you can
get a very high compliance
cool no thank you for explaining that so
you mentioned the clinical trials and i
was just wondering like obviously i
guess um
one big question is um
how like safe would um implementing
fasting mimicking diets be and then for
the rest of your life and i was just
wondering like what is the longest uh
trial that you've done so far or are in
the process of of uh doing
um to see um
how many times fmd can be done and like
look at more long-term safety
consequences
yeah so um
we are about to publish a paper that
also includes a survey of thousands of
uh patients or doctors of i think 400
doctors that follow thousands of
patients
and the good news which is kind of
surprising we really seen rarely even
people
ending up in the hospital right and now
once it gets to thousands of people you
you expect that you know some people
by chance will will end up uh
with with grade 3 4
side effects but we really
are not seeing that so that's the
biggest um
that's the biggest
evidence i think coming from uh
all the people that are doing it out
there
um
and some people have been doing it for
years and and so far
i mean you usually hear um i think the
companies also um
obliged to report it right so
uh to the fda so should somebody have
you know severe side effects
um yeah so so far we haven't seen it
that doesn't mean that there couldn't be
some but uh
we haven't seen it so i would say that
that seems to be very safe and it was
also designed to be that so it wasn't
designed lots of times we get people to
say why why don't you have less sugar
why don't you have less starches why
don't you have you know um
less calories etc
and uh and and part of the the
development
of the of the fasting making diet for
for everybody
not for cancer patient but for for
everyone was to um get a less a little
bit less of an effect and more safety
uh thinking of
um you know what if everybody did this
you know let's say between age 20 and
age 70 um we
the burden is to
if you if you want to take a healthy
person
and you know you work in an aging right
so so no matter what we come up with
um if you intervene on a sick person
there is a certain degree of tolerance
for side effects right so hey if you
have cancer if alzheimer's yes somebody
could die even because of the therapy
but there's nothing you can do but if
somebody's healthy right then you have a
different problem a different
burden
and you have to make sure almost nobody
ever dies
so or even almost nobody ever has severe
side effects and and that's that's a
very difficult that's a very high
um
high
burden
and yeah but that's what we've been
focusing on uh
making it so that
that we rarely really see see problems
with it
you